picture this a field stretching far into
the Horizon rows upon rows of green
Spears reaching for the sky this is no
ordinary field but an asparagus Farm
here Farmers cultivate and harvest
millions of these nutritious stocks
yearly using Innovative farming
technology first off asparagus isn't
grown from seeds instead Farmers plant
one-year-old crowns essentially
asparagus Roots which can produce for up
to 20 years talk about a Green Thumb
next up the Harvest did you know that
asparagus can grow up to 10 in in a day
that's right Farmers have to harvest
daily to keep up these farmers use
specialized Machinery designed to cut
the asparagus stocks without damaging
the plant ensuring a fresh batch will
grow back swiftly from the field to your
plate asparagus farming is a Marvel of
modern agriculture combining traditional
methods with advanced technology so next
time you enjoy this green delight
remember the journey it's taken